>> BEAUTIFUL, STRONG, GORGEOUS
AT ANY SIZE.
>> YOU'RE A WOMAN AND YOU
DESERVE CLOTHES THAT FIT AND
FLATTER.
YOU ARE CONFIDENT.
>> SO CONFIDENT.
>> PROVE THEM WRONG.
YOU ROCK.
>> I ROCK IT.
>> YOU RULE THE WORLD.
>> HELL, YES, I DO.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU SHOP AT CHONK.
WE KNOW WHAT WOMEN WANT.
YOU WANT TO BE GLAMOUROUS.
WE KNOW NOT EVERY WOMAN IS A
RUNWAY MODEL.
THAT'S WHY CHONK OFFERS SIZES
TWO TO 28 YOU'RE A QUEEN.
YOU'RE A GODDESS.
YOU'RE CHONK.
>> HEAD TO TOE CHONK.
>> NO MATTER WHAT SIZE YOU ARE,
YOU'LL STILL FEEL CHONK.
>> NO.
>> WE'RE THE ONLY ONE THAT
ACCEPTS YOUR UNIQUE BODY.
>> UNIQUE?
>> AND TRY OUR TWEEN GIRLS
DEPARTMENT.
>> NO, I DON'T WANT THIS FOR MY
DAUGHTER.
NO.
>> CHONK, CHONK, CHONK.
>> AND FOR THE GUY IN YOUR LIFE,
VISIT OUR MEN'S STORE, NORMAL
CLOTHES.
>> WELL THIS SHIRT FITS ME.
>> ME TOO.
I GOT EVERYTHING I NEEDED.
>> YEAH, NO PROBLEMS HERE.
>> SWEET.
>> EVERY WOMAN IS A CHONK!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪